[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
quand j'étais petite je venais ici voir
des Balas et des opéras j'étais toute
contente et tout
intimidée un peu comme
aujourd'hui vous savez que dans cette
opéra il y a un
fantôme c'est difficile à dire parce
qu'il est bien caché mais il est là
c'est le fantôme non pas de la nature
j'aime pas trop ce mot mais du monde
vivant prenez la forêt par exemple dans
cet opéra comme dans une forêt il y a
des saisons des champs des répertoires
de champs autour de nous il y a ces
grands piliers Corinthiens avec leur
feuillage en haut qui font un peu comme
de grands ares majestueux deant qu'ils
entourent ce grand espace ouvert au
centre un peu en clairière qu'on appelle
le
parterre puis a tous les yeux qui
observent à des hauteurs différentes
dans la pénombre qui moi me font penser
à tous les animaux qui guettent la nuit
vous voyez comme ça perché aux
différents étages de la forêt ce qu'on
appelle la
canopée ce serait quoi après tout une
culture qui se développe pas dans des
bâtiments pas dans des boîtes mais au
contact direct du monde vivant si demain
on a plus la potion magique qui nous a
permis de bâtir partout plein de cinéma
de théâtres de musées si bientôt on a
plus les quantités énormes d'énergies
fossile et de métaux qu'il nous faut
pour construire la culture
et le monde d'ailleurs comme on le fait
aujourd'hui comment on pourrait
continuer à trouver autour de nous dans
le monde vivant des formes de culture
qui nous fascinent et qui nous
nourrissent autant que j'étais fasciné
et nourri quand je venais ici quand
j'étais petite toute contente et toute
intimidée à
l'Opéra c'est vrai quand nous les
humains on vient dans ce lieu on dit
qu'on se cultive mais est-ce qu'on
pourrait aussi se cultiver comme les
plantes en pleine terre en plein
champ a priori trouver la culture dans
le monde vivant c'est pas évident quand
les gens disaient d'une amie de ma
grand-mère qu'elle se choait à la
culture c'est pas qu'elle allait se
rouler dans les prés gambader dans les
marais ou explorer la forêt non c'est
qu'elle allait tout le temps au cinéma
au théâtre au musée ensuite pour une
grande partie d'entre nous on nhabite
pas dans des lieux vivants quand on
passe du temps pour les vacances par
exemple dans des endroits où il y a ni
musée ni monuments ni aucun truc où des
humains racontent des histoires à
d'autres humains à visiter mais on est
beaucoup je pense à pas se sentir nourri
stimulé à se sentir un peu vide et
certains d'entre nous quand ils
rentreront en ville diront peut-être
même bah c'était beau mais il y avait
rien à
faire puis enfin en France on est le
peuple des lumières on est rationaliste
bien sûr on sait que notre rapport à la
nature il est problématique et des fois
on aimerait bien copier un peu les
peuple amérindien sibérien parce que
chez eux par exemple la vie culturelle
est indissociable du monde vivant nature
et culture sont pas des choses
séparées mais bon nous on est cartésien
et fier de l'être et c'est pas
maintenant que ça va
changer ça c'est un peu l'histoire qu'on
se raconte c'est le récit qu'on entend
beaucoup sur qui on serait nous les
Français nous les
occidentaux pourtant si on se réinscrit
dans le temps long si on élargit la
focale bah la réalité de cette
séparation entre nature et culture chez
nous elle est loin d'être évidente
jusqu'à a pas si longtemps nos économies
elles étaient locales nos société
étaaiit paysanes rural en 1845 75 % des
Français étaient paysans et un siècle
plus tard en 1945 la France est encore
décrite comme une société de petits
paysans libres attachés à leur terre nos
cultures aussi jusqu'à il y a peu de
temps elles étaient locales autochton
elles se foraient au contact direct des
territoires et de leur monde vivant au
contact des langages de ces mondes
vivants leur expressivité de leur
capacité à faire siges il y avait des
arbres guérisseurs auxquels on allait
accrocher ses vêtements quand on faisait
des prix en friche en Bretagne c'était
bon pour le sol mais c'était aussi parce
que les fites aimaient s'y reposer il y
avait des Gobelins qui donnaient des
coups de main au jardinage des grêurs
qui assemblaient les orages derrière ces
vie rie poussiéreuse qu'on appelle le
folklore il y avait comme dit
l'anthropologue Charles stépanov toute
une exploration paysane de l'invisible
exploration qui prenait pour support le
monde vivant et qui générait une
quantité de de récit de légendes de
savoir encoder et encrypt dans des
histoires tout ça ça produisait une
forme de culture bien particulière qui
existe encore aujourd'hui même si elle
est pas très visible c'est la culture
qui apparaît quand le lieu où on vit
devient suffisamment riche en vie
suffisamment enforesté pour que notre
imaginaire trouve à s'en nourrir qui s'y
installe et se mette à pousser à travers
lui c'est la culture qui se forme quand
ce qu'on habite devient ce qui nous
habite cette culture on peut lui donner
un nom en réactivant un mot un peu
obsolète un peu oublié aujourd'hui et
pourtant qu' a un beau mot le mot de
vernaculaire pourquoi c'est un beau mot
ben parce que le mot vernaculaire en
français il s'emploie pour désigner des
langues les langues vernaculaires qui
sont des langues locales et il s'emploie
aussi pour désigner des habitats les
habitats vernaculaires qui sont des
formes d'habitat régionales typique
local encore une fois donc dans ce mot
il y a cette idée qui est assez belle
que nos habitats et nos langages sont
comme cousus ensemble qui sont comme les
deux faces d'une seule et même chose la
culture vernaculaire pour moi c'est donc
pas juste l'idée d'une culture locale
c'est la culture qui apparaît quand le
lieu où on habite nous donne les moyens
de dire le monde et quand ce qu'on dit
sur le monde puiss sa forme et ses
forces dans le lieu où on
habite vous savez peut-être que les
ruminants ils ont plusieurs ventres ils
ont un ventre à quatre poches mais le
vernaculaire c'est un peu ce qui se
passe quand on devient capable de
trouver autour de soi dans le monde
vivant de quoi nourrir les différents
ventres qu'on cache nous aussi dans
notre notre corps le ventre métabolique
mais aussi le ventre sensible le ventre
cognitif le ventre
imaginaire alors bien sûr les maisons
des ancêtres elles étaient pas en sucre
et en chocolat c'est pas ce que je suis
en train de dire elles étaient beaucoup
plus sobres beaucoup plus austères mais
il y avait cette idée que la culture et
le monde vivant marchaent main dans la
main qu'ils étaient entremêlés
maintenant pourquoi on est sorti de ce
modèle pourquoi on est sorti de ces
sociétés qui entretenaient à la fois des
écosystèmes stables et des cultures
singulières bah on en est sorti c'est
pas par appâ du gain l'assitude ou aussi
comme on l'entend beaucoup parce que les
sirènes de la modernité nous auraient
complètement envoûé si on en est sorti
c'est surtout parce qu'un arsenal de
politique des politiques extractivistes
capitalistes ont mis en place
méthodiquement depuis 200 ans la
disparition des alternatives donc il y a
eu la destruction des communs des droits
d'usage de la policulture traditionnelle
il y a eu l'exode rural le démembrement
l'extraction des ressources des territo
ir ruraux ce qui fait qu'on peut d'une
certaine manière relire l'histoire des
deux siècles derniers comme l'histoire
d'e véritable colonisation intérieure
qui aurait extrait les ressources des
sociétés locales détruit leur culture et
qui les a comme comme le dit M céser sur
le colonialisme ils a vidé d'elles-même
maintenant ce qu'il y a d'intéressant
avec la culture c'est que c'est quelque
chose de très couriace de très sauvage
qui repousse son crier gare qui
disparaît jamais
complètement connaissez peut-être cette
cette phrase assez célèbre la culture
c'est ce qui reste quand on a tout
oublié ben notre histoire vernaculaire
notre culture vie du monde vivant c'est
pareil elles sont pas très loin de nous
elles survivent à beaucoup de choses
elles survivent à
l'oubli comme tous les colonisés on se
débat à bas Bru moi je suis la petite
fille d'un paysan sartois d'un côté et
de l'autre côté d'un guérisseur algérien
né dans les montagnes des orè donc sur
les deux bords de la Méditerranée j'ai
des ancêtres t plus ou moins ouvertement
plus ou moins violemment
on a effacé les mondes et pourtant il y
a pas si longtemps ses ancêtres ils
m'ont fait signe ils sont revenus me
chercher je vais vous raconter cette
histoire qui est l'histoire de comment
j'ai retrouvé tout près de nous dans le
monde d'aujourd'hui des cultures
vernaculaires ou des maison qui se mange
cette histoire commence il y a quelques
années je faisais un petit boulot
d'interprète sur un salon de mobilier
porte de versaill et là un homme vient
me voir et il me dit une phrase vous
n'avez pas votre place et il
repart alors je suis restée un peu
interloquée et pour être très honnête
j'ai jamais vraiment compris je pense
que je comprendrai vraiment jamais ce
qui s'est passé ce jour-là mais à
postériori je me suis dit que c'était
finalement assez vrai ce qui m'avait dit
cet homme et c'était pas non plus àodin
que ça se soit passé sur un salon de
mobilier pourquoi bah parce qu'à cette
époque j'étais effectivement comme tous
les meubles autour de moi transportable
transposable en transition sans ancrage
sans maison j'étais un peu dans dans une
phase de crise existentielle que je
vivais comme quelque chose de personnel
mais aussi comme quelque chose qui nous
touchait qui nous touchait tous un petit
peu plus collectivement donc pour rompre
avec cette pa de repère j'ai décidé
comme on dit beaucoup aujourd'hui de
bifurquer d'expérimenter d'autres modes
de vie de me former à l'autonomie j'ai
décidé d'aller passer du temps dans des
lieux autonomes c'estàd des lieux dont
les habitants un peu comme les paysans
d'autrefois cherchent à réinscrire leurs
besoins quotidiens dans le monde vivant
essaie de produire eux-même leur énergie
leur nourriture leur logement
donc j'ai commencé ce voyage qui est
devenu une sorte d'enquête j'ai allaéis
dans des écolieux dans des fermes en
permaculture dans des ades dans des
maisons autonomes et ce que j'ai
constaté pour commencer c'est que ces
lieux de vie autonomees leur grande
particularité c'est qu'il mélangent les
corps pour fonctionner ils vont
concentrer les énergies et les matières
donc ils vont concentrer le vivant
animal et végétal ils vont concentrer
les matériaux avec des tas des stocks
des composts qui apparaissent un peu
partout les énergies aussi de manière bi
climatique en capturant les énergies
présentes sur le lieu et ils vont
concentrer aussi les fonctions des
espaces et des objets ça ça produit des
apparitions étranges comme par exemple
le tractopoule qu'est-ce que c'est le
tractopoule c'est un poulailler mobile
qui permet d'abriter les poules de
fertiliser le sol au fur et à mesure de
l'ameublir mais qui dessine aussi les
contours d'une sorte de nouvell
créatures mythologique à mchement entre
la volaille et le tracteur ce qu' a
d'intéressant là-dedans c'est que les
lieux autonomes donc il mélangent les
corps voit bien avec le tractopoule il
mélange aussi les imaginaires attachés à
ses corps les signes attachés à ses
corps du coup l'habitat tout entier de
une sorte de fabrique à métaphore de
machine à brasser de métier à tisser les
images les corps les identités des
choses et des
êtres l'exemple le plus parlant
peut-être de tous ces lieux que j'ai
visité c'est chez Sylvie barbe à quant
auyourt Sylvie avant elle travaillait
comme couturière et elle est passé
progressivement de la couture de
vêtements à la couture de work de
yourourt et sa forêt toute entière
puisquelle vit aujourd'hui dans les
svenes dans ce qu'on pourrait appeler
une forêt brodée c'estàdire un bout de
forêt dont les recoins les chemins les
clarières se recouvrent de lainees
d'installation tissu de guirlandes qui
vont longer les terrasses s'en rouler
autour des trons donc on a vraiment chez
Sylvie une pratique qui va mélanger
coudre ensemble les humains et les
nonhains les inclure dans un même tissu
un tissu très physique concret pour
l'autonomie mais qui se double aussi
d'un tissu esthétique sensible
imaginaire du coup la forêt de Sylvie
elle devient un monde propre une culture
propre et Sylvie elle me l'a dit
elle-même elle m'a dit je me divertis
plus j'ai plus besoin de vacances ni de
divertissement je sais qu'il y a plein
de choses qui vont se passer des choses
nouvelles qui vont me passionner des
traces au sol des plantes pliées par un
passage tout ça ça raconte des
histoires et elle a ajouté une phrase
qui est Deven très importante pour moi
ma culture c'est ma forêt mais quand
Syvie m'a dit ça je me suis rendu compte
que j'avais trouvé tout près de nous
dans le monde d'aujourd'hui des exemples
bien concrets vivaces contemporains de
culture vernaculaire ou de maisons qui
se Mang c'està-dire des maisons
nourricières où la nourriture pousse
dans tous les sens à tous les étages des
maisons qui mangent leurs déchets
recyclent le plus possible leurs
énergies et leurs matières donc qui se
mangent elles-même quelque part et qui
sont aussi des maisons faire de son
environnement une nourriture
existentielle alors maintenant je
regarde à nouveau autour de moi et je me
dis qu'on est quand même très loin chez
Sylvie ici on voit le grand écart qui se
creuse entre les cultures forêts dont je
viens de vous parler et le lieu où on
est aujourd'hui pourtant ce grand écart
il est intéressant aussi parce qu'il
nous montre le grand espace qu'arrive à
couvrir si on la déploie dans toute son
extension cette chose très souple et
mystérieuse qu'on appelle la culture
quand on entre chez Sylvie sur le pas de
la porte au sol il y a des clés il y a
une ribembelle de clés qui bordent le
seuil un peu comme une frise comme un
ruban je me suis longtemps demandé ce
qu'elle faisait là ces clés mais
peut-être que ce qu'elles nous disent
dans le fond c'est que les clés qu'on
cherche pour affronter nos problèmes le
réchauffement climatique l'effondrement
de vivant sont pas très loin sous nos
pieds là où on habite et qui suffit de
gratter un peu le sol de le jardiner un
peu pour les faire
apparaître vous savez on parle beaucoup
du fait que nos systèmes énergétiques se
sont pas substitués mais additionnés les
uns aux autres le pétrole a pas remplacé
le charbon il s'est ajouté à lui pour le
droit c'est la même chose la plupart de
nos lois elles se remplac pas ell
s'empil on a ce qu'on appelle un
feuilleté juridique bah pour nos
cultures nos ontologies c'est pareil
pour la plupart ell se remplacent pas
elles s'empilent les unes sur les autres
et on vit comme ça sur un espèce de
feuilleté de cosmovision de rapport au
monde ce ce que ce feuilleté il nous
raconte c'est que la culture ça peut
être de trouver les histoires inscrites
dans le lieu où on est de digérer ces
histoires de les
incorporé la prochaine fois que vous
allez non pas dans la nature mais dans
un lieu où il y a de la vie pas
seulement de la vie humaine mais plein
de formes de vie essayez de voir les
différents êtres qui habitent là de
percevoir leurs signes leur manière de
vivre les histoires qui raconte
essz de vous demander quel récit légende
savoir les habitants de ce territoire
ont pu autrefois construire patiemment
collectivement à partir des petites
brindilles de sens qui trouvaient sur
place
essayer de sentir comment ces tissu très
fragiles ont pu être détricoté et
comment on pourrait aussi si on s'en
donnait la peine comme s'il vit dans sa
forêt les
reconstituer il y a un petit animal que
j'aime beaucoup cet animal c'est le
tricoptère tricoptère c'est un groupe
d'insectes qui a pour particularité
quand ils sont petits de s'engoncer dans
dans des fourreaux des sortes de robes
multicolore multifacettes qu'ils
assemblent à partir de ce qui les
environne ça peut être des débris des
graviers des
brindilles B la culture ça peut être ce
bel opéra autour de nous avec tous les
champs les personnages les artistes les
chezdœuvre qui le
H ça peut être aussi une culture de
tricoptère quelque chose qui traverse
les époques qui dépend pas du degré de
complexité technique sociale énergétique
d'une société
ça peut être quelque chose qui apparaît
avec le monde vivant avec ses
manifestations et ses économies les plus
simples et les plus
dépouillé ça peut être la culture tout
simplement de collecter les petits
éclats de signes de sens les petits
éclats d'importance qu'on trouve autour
de soi et d'en faire comme le tricoptère
un habit protecteur une seconde peau un
organe qui nous aide à
vivre merci
[Musique]